من البر والبحر والجو تشتد حمله القصف
الصاروخي الروسي على مختلف مناطق اوكرانيا
فتنعكي بمزيدا من القتل المدنيين ويحل
الدمار الهائل بما تبقى لها من منشات
بيان لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اكد ان
القوات الروسيه اطلقت 49 صاروخا باتجاه
مواقع مختلفه حيث سقط مدنيون قتل وجرحى
كما اتهم البيان تلك القوات بشن سبع
وثلاثين غاره واطلاق قذائفه من رجمات
الصواريخ على المناطق السكنيه خلال
الساعات الماضيه الجانب الروسي الذي ينكر
باستمرار استهداف المدنيين اعلن ان
مروحيات هجوميه نفذت عده غارات على مواقع
اللواء الميكانيكي الرابعه عشر في الجيش
الاوكراني ووحدات الدفاع الاقليميه
الاوكرانيه المنتشره في محور كوبيانسك
كما اعلنت القوات الروسيه ان مقاتلات نفذت
ضربتين جويتين على مواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في خاركيف تحدث القاده
العسكريون الروس ايضا عن صدق قواتهم هجمات
اوكرانيه في عده جبهات وقتل عشرات
العسكريين الاوكرانيين واسر بعضهم
منطقه اوديس الاوكرانيه على البحر الاسود
ما تزال ضمن بنك الاهداف الروسيه المحببه
يوميا وهي قبل ساعات تعرضت لوابل جديد من
صواريخ سفن الاسطول الروسي وتقول ان
الهجمات الروسيه على اوديسا اصبحت اكثر
ضراوه بعد انهيار اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
وبحسب نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني دمر
الروس 26 مرفقا من مرافق البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ كما دمروا 5 سفن مدنيه خلال تسعه
ايام
واذا كانت تكيف وموسكو تتكتمان عن الخسائر
في الميدان فالواضح ان مختلف خطوط
الاشتباك تشهد تصعيدا عسكريا ومقابل كثافه
القصف الروسي تواصل اوكرانيا هجومها
المضاد وتدفع بمزيد من القوات الى مناطق
جنوب شرق البلاد معززه باسلحه غربيه
متطوره مكنتها حتى الان من استعاده بعض
الاراضي او على الاقل الحفاظ على مواقعها
في محاور الايمان
ومارينا وبخموت في مقاطعه دونيسك وفق هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه